le Loir-et-Cher aurait perdu 18% de ses
exploitations agricoles entre 2010 et
2020 heureusement beaucoup encore
continuent avec passion leur activité ce
week-end il s'était donné rendez-vous à
torrellarochette dans le Loir-et-Cher
pour ce qui était le temps d'un week-end
la plus grande ferme du département le
commissaire de Torrey a rassemblé plus
de 20 000 personnes sur deux jours
l'occasion de voir de près des animaux
de goûter à des produits locaux mais
aussi de découvrir comment son produit
nos aliments reportage de Florent Clavel
et Hélène chapelet
pour faire un commissaire réussi il faut
d'abord de gros tracteurs et ça tombe
bien ce quadra 620 chevaux nous est
présenté comme le plus puissant du monde
son prix 600000 euros il faut également
des animaux et des agriculteurs
passionnés par leur métier c'est le cas
de Christian éleveur de Blonde
d'Aquitaine à couture qui pose devant
deux de ses bêtes aujourd'hui les
tournages de partir à la retraite mais
faute de repreneur pour son exploitation
il continue de travailler moi je
démarrais en 85 avec 12 mers allaitantes
aujourd'hui on en a 100 j'ai quand même
acquis une certaine génétique et ça
m'embêterait que tout soit cassé parte à
la boucherie
donc je voudrais bien que ça continue
l'arrivée imprévu de la pluie samedi
après-midi n'avancement pas réussi à
doucher l'enthousiasme des visiteurs une
fois les précipitations passées ils ont
pu poursuivre leur tour des 155
exposants présents
les choses nouvelles l'évolution de mon
agricole et puis en même temps
va rencontrer aussi des personnes de
connaissance voilà
tout ce qui se passe et puis notamment
pour voir les élèves qui sont juste
derrière et qui vont présenter des
vaches demain
10 ans après un premier passage à
torré-la-rochette le commissaire reste
une valeur sûre en termes de
fréquentation selon les organisateurs
plus de 20 000 visiteurs se sont rendus
sur place durant le weekend